on va plus loin avec AMDA mostaf Avid a
écrit 7 juin de la rédaction de
L'Express bonjour hamdom L'Express qui
quitte cette semaine sur la face cachée
du bien-être yoga naturopathie
ostéopathie et plus encore c'est-à-dire
dans l'Express gothierry binsky
chroniqueur étincel de France 24 est
également à mes côtés bonjour Gauthier
bonsoir le Royaume-Uni va donc avoir un
nouveau Premier ministre rien de plus
richissonnax a désignation a été aussi
rapide que les événements qui l'ont
porté au pouvoir ont été chaotiques
associés expliquent d'ailleurs sans
doute cela que tient les conservateurs
avec trop à se faire pardonner le vous
pouvez pas se permettre un nouveau
psychodrame
on va voir si c'est fini avec jissonnac
est-ce que c'est vraiment fini oui si
vous voulez le psychodrame dont vous
parlez il est quand même le fait d'une
rigidité extrême d'un parti qui se
cherche d'un parti qui n'a pas si vous
voulez
dans sa dans son affecte qui n'a pas
survécu au drame du brexit qui croit
toujours que le brexit est la pas
possible et puis de l'autre qui était
l'un des avocats
exactement mais alors la question est de
savoir est-ce que lui il va aller droit
dans le mur comme l'a fait list trust
c'est à dire en campant sur des
positions doctrinaires ou bien est-ce
qu'il va comprendre que sa longévité à
lui et son influence sur le cours de
l'économie britannique passe par de
l'eau dans le vin c'est à dire tout
simplement ne pas être accroché à cette
doctrine il l'a déjà fait puisqu'en 2020
il avait décroché une grosse enveloppe
pour contrer les effets néfastes du
brexit donc c'est ça au fond c'est je
m'arrête là mais c'est la redéfinition
de l'idéologie et de la pensée des
conservateurs mais qui se fait à ciel
ouverte c'est-à-dire sur le dos enfin on
espère pas trop longtemps mais sur le
dos de la population et là c'est le jeu
politique qui est étonnamment biaisé si
vous voulez puisque on est tous les
Britanniques sont suspendus à la
nomination d'un nouveau
représentant conservateur qui lui-même
n'est nommé que en l'occurrence par des
élus mais on va les goûter justement
riches une dans sa première réaction
après sa victoire faut de l'adversaire
je me sens modeste et je suis en même
temps honoré d'avoir le soutien de mes
collègues parlementaires et d'être élu
comme dirigeant du Parti conservateur et
unioniste c'est le plus grand privilège
de ma vie d'être en mesure de servir le
parti que j'adore et de redonner au pays
à auquel je dois tant le Royaume-Uni est
un grand pays
mais je suis convaincu que nous sommes
dans une situation de défier économique
très grand nous avons besoin de
stabilité d'unités et ce sera ma plus
grande priorité de faire en sorte que
notre partie et notre pays se solidarise
que représente
le Royaume-Uni l'accession d'un enfant
de l'immigration comme richissounac au
sommet du pouvoir oui c'est vrai que
j'allais vous dire que avec tout ce
psychodrame on a quand même une tendance
à oublier que c'est le premier Premier
ministre non blanc du Royaume-Uni ça
représente qu'un retardé sur son arrivée
vous pensez ça c'est difficile à savoir
étant donné on sait que ceux qui avaient
en tout cas voté pour listrot c'était
plutôt des hommes blancs c'était les
adhérents du parti conservateur donc
c'était voilà pas une population
forcément mais tu sais après je pense
que le symbole est fort mais ça s'arrête
au symbole pourquoi parce que riches
unak ça reste quelqu'un vraiment de l'É
ce sont ces grands-parents qui sont
arrivés au Royaume-Uni donc il y a déjà
voilà plusieurs c'est déjà plusieurs
générations d'intégration Royaume-Uni il
a fait toutes les meilleures écoles
Winchester collège Oxford Stanford aux
États-Unis il est marié à une femme
indienne qui est multi milliardaire de
qui est la fille d'un multimilliardaire
voilà ça c'est c'est bien mais c'est pas
un homme du peuple voilà il raconte un
peu toujours lui-même sa vie comme une
sorte de success story mais magnifique
mais voilà ça reste encore heureux que
j'ai envie de dire qu'après deux
générations quand on a fait les
meilleurs écoles on puisse accéder à ce
poste là voilà c'est ça reste technique
mais pas forcément social en fait ça
n'allait pas de choix pour autant pour
nombre d'électeurs conservateurs qui lui
avaient préférée ou autour d'adhérents
comme vient de le dire à Madame du
particulier il y a un vieux fonds
xénophobe chez les conservateurs comme
on l'a souvent dit antisémite du côté
des travaillistes Gauthier oui
antisémite c'était clair avec Jeremy
corbyn qui a jamais réussi d'ailleurs
c'est des négations étaient un peu un
peu faiblarde il a jamais réussi
vraiment à donner la preuve que le Parti
travailliste dans certaines de ces
marges avaient oui le l'antisémitisme
classique qui consiste à dire que la
City de Londres est aux mains des Juifs
en Grande-Bretagne comme partout
ailleurs il y a beaucoup plus de Juifs
pauvres que enfin je veux dire on en est
là malheureusement à être obligé de
redresser les choses de cette façon là
mais côté conservateur c'est aussi la
même chose que je disais Hamdam c'est à
dire il y a une mixité ethnique c'est à
dire qu'on dit finalement oui vous êtes
là on peut vivre ensemble surtout ce
côtoyer mais n'essayez pas d'avoir les
aspirations que que peut avoir un blanc
comme nous comme les les Britanniques et
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a alors ça
c'est tout le problème du
multiculturalisme à la Britannique
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas quelque
chose de
d'assimilationner si on peut dire qui
qui intègre c'est quelque chose qui
éventuellement oui laisse passer de
temps en temps des personnages comme ça
et c'était vrai que c'est la première
fois et qui n'est pas dans le système
lui-même fait pour promouvoir des
personnes qui seraient issues de
minorité mais encore une fois c'est vrai
que de par son parcours il n'est plus
qu'une il n'est plus il fait plus partie
d'une minorité c'est un peu si vous
voulez le l'exception qui confirme la
règle c'est celui qui passe
effectivement au travers mais parce que
il a une assise sociale et
intellectuelle mais malgré tout ça il
faut le reconnaître le vote ou les
adhérents auxquels les adhérents ont
pris part ont effectivement rangé Sonnac
très loin derrière l'histoire et ça
partait de ça alors que l'élite
conservatrice elle peut considérer
qu'elle se passe de ce genre de
Gauthier je suis d'accord avec vous et
j'ai aussi tempéré mais voilà c'est ce
qui se produit en Angleterre ne s'est
jamais produit en France pour l'instant
donc où on a quand même l'immigration
qui date il y a pas eu
de Premier ministre on a eu plein de
ministres évidemment d'origine
maghrébine ou d'Afrique ou peu importe
mais c'est vrai qu'en France on n'a pas
eu symboliquement voilà c'est bon c'est
ma tentative pour devenir première
ministre
aura singulièrement tout de même
compliqué la tâche de richissouna comme
d'hab mais elle lui laisse un pays plus
appauvri que s'il était devenu premier
ministre il y a un mois et demi lorsque
déjà les sondages en tout cas auprès des
députés le placer en tête alors là oui
il y a quand même un million de
Britanniques qui bascule là en ce moment
cette année dans la pauvreté d'après des
chiffres qui sont sortis il y a un mois
à peu près donc on est à peu près à 16
millions de de personnes qui sont sous
le seuil de pauvreté dans un pays qui en
compte 47 en France pour donner
l'équivalence et peu moins de 10
millions donc voilà c'est quand même
assez significatif il a une situation
très compliquée pour pour les
Britanniques les Britanniques lambda
j'ai envie de dire les gens qui sont
confrontés à l'inflation et il a aussi
une situation compliquée vis-à-vis des
milieux d'affaires qui ont quand même
beaucoup
manifester leur incompréhension par
rapport à la politique du gouvernement
alors lui a quand même cette expérience
plus ancienne justement de chancelier de
l'Échiquier il a quand même normalement
une certaine confiance des marchés donc
on peut espérer que la stabilité
reviendra rapidement si politiquement il
est pas soumis à des coups par ailleurs
de des membres de son propre parti parce
que dans son propre parti dans son parti
il y a vraiment tous les conservateurs
ça va de jakobastock qui est un assez
illuminé voilà qui veut ramener
l'Angleterre à l'époque victorienne on a
on a Johnson évidemment qui certes c'est
rangé là mais
maintenant en tout cas que que aux
affaires avec les promesses d'orthodoxie
budgétaire que Boris Johnson du moins
temporairement est rentré dans le rang
les conservateurs Gauthier vont-ils
pouvoir s'épargner des des élections
législatives anticipées on les disait
quasiment inévitable la semaine dernière
ça semble moins sûr ce soir
ça semble moins sûr parce que si vous
voulez il y a forcément une aspiration
un peu à l'apaisement au calme y compris
pour les citoyens britanniques et que le
fait que le leader des travailistes qui
restreur soit là à réclamer en
permanence et avec un assistance la
tenue d'élection générale peut-être que
ça joue contre lui mais dans le même
temps c'est vrai que ça serait la seule
solution c'est à dire de retourner
devant les électeurs pour la raison
qu'on a indiqué tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que c'est une infime partie
du parti donc conservateur qui a la main
sur le destin dans les années ou même
les mois qui viennent de la société
britannique c'est le premier point et le
deuxième point aussi c'est que ce parti
qui a bénéficié en 2019 d'un appoint
substantiel de voix qui venait notamment
du Nord et des classes populaires de
l'Angleterre avec une formation
finalement un habitus travailliste et
qui sont passés chez les conservateurs
en disant mais nous on passe pas sur les
conservateurs pour réclamer la
dérégulation totale par exemple on est
pour un une certaine
un maintien de l'intervention étatique
dans les affaires et d'autres sujets
comme ça et c'est un peu comme si le
parti comme les terrorisme n'avait pas
tenu compte de cela et qu'il s'était
livré à des jeux on va dire extrémistes
avec l'histoire et qu'il n'avait pas
tenu compte et ça veut dire aussi que si
ils sont aujourd'hui dans les sondages
distants ils peuvent compter sur
peut-être les deux ans qui viennent pour
se refaire une santé c'est-à-dire tenir
compte de cette marge importante des
lecteurs qui à l'origine ne sont pas
concernés mais ce que vous décrivez
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec le brexit
après tout c'est à dire que j'ai
l'impression qu'on Angleterre on ne
revote pas on accepte que ce soit seul
une minorité la population enfin voilà
compte de laisser beaucoup de gens sur
le sur le sur le carreau de gouverner
avec cette de cette manière un peu
unilatérale on va dire
le péril nucléaire est-il à nos portes
en Ukraine on a toujours aucune
indication mais mes Moscou continue
d'agiter la menace cette fois en
accusant l'Ukraine de préparer une bombe
sale autrement dit des explosifs
conventionnelles entourés de matériaux
radioactifs et ceux à la fin des
disséminer dans l'atmosphère lors de
l'explosion écouter la réponse par qui
est de volodies
russe de la Défense met en place un
manège téléphonique et appelle les
ministres étrangers avec des histoires
de soi-disant bon nucléaires sales tout
le monde comprend bien ils comprennent
qui est à l'origine de toutes les
saletés qui peuvent être imaginées dans
cette guerre
si la Russie passe ses appels et prétend
que l'Ukraine prépare quelque chose cela
signifie surtout que la Russie a déjà
tout préparé je pense que maintenant le
monde devrait réagir aussi durement que
possible
c'est ça le procédé qu'il faut craindre
de la part des Russes qui n'assume
finalement les Ukrainiens d'une menace
qu'il s'apprête eux-mêmes à mettre à
l'exécution
il est certain que on a pu remarquer
depuis le début de cette guerre que
c'est évidemment une guerre sur le
terrain mais c'est beaucoup aussi une
guerre de propagande une guerre des
esprits une guerre psychologiques ça
fait quand même plusieurs jours que les
Russes
menacent de créer une sorte d'hiver
[Musique]
glacial à Kiev et dans le reste de
l'Ukraine en bombardant les
installations électriques il y a eu
toute une série voilà d'actions qui
laissent penser que Moscou voyant qui
perd l'ascendant finalement sur le
terrain essaye de prendre l'ascendant
psychologique dans le budget j'imagine
la supposition parce que c'est un peu
que se passe-t-il dans la tête de
Poutine mais bon dans le but j'imagine
que les Occidentaux soient plus frileux
sur leur soutien à l'Ukraine et du coup
voilà de potentiellement regagner donc
seul seul
ça peut esprit voilà c'est la seule
chose à mon avis qui veut expliquer je
ne pense pas je préfère le formuler que
les Ukrainiens préparent une bombe sale
Gautier la Russie on serait tenté dire
c'est de la sur enchères de la menace
mais non puisque depuis le début en fait
quasiment elle agite cette menace
nucléaire il y a un moment sans
évidemment le souhaiter loin de là mais
qu'on se demande si elle se matérialise
pas concrètement est-ce qu'il y a pas un
problème de crédibilité même des Russes
à en revenir sans cesse finalement à
cette hypothèse oui oui bien sûr parce
que vous avez raison de souligner que
très vite Poutine quasiment même je
crois le soir même enfin la veille de
l'invasion il avait signalé que ceux qui
tenteraient de s'opposer à l'action de
la Russie serait frappé comme il ne
l'avait jamais connu auparavant alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'il avait anticipé
c'est difficile à dire est-ce qu'il est
anticipé les difficultés opérationnelles
en termes de guerre conventionnelle
qu'il allait rencontrer je ne crois pas
mais il y a cette volonté effectivement
d'impressionner d'emblée de frapper fort
et de joindre à l'époque c'était de
joindre l'opérationnel et le psychologie
de dissuader d'emblée toute résistance
voilà ça n'a pas marché et donc vous
voyez bien effectivement pour rejoindre
ce que diamdam c'est qu'à à chaque fois
que sur le plan militaire quelque chose
cloche on a recours tout de suite après
à d'autres justificatifs qui sont
effectivement la par exemple la bombe
finalement dans le discours alors que
jusqu'à présent et encore heureux bien
sûr et on le souhaite tous et et les
Russes eux-mêmes certainement parce que
ce n'est pas leur intérêt non plus d'y
avoir recours mais pourquoi dans ce cas
il revenir en permanence Washington
l'indique nous nous n'avons aucune
indication à ce stade un mouvement de
russe faisant des troupes russes faisant
usage d'armes chimiques biologique
bactériologique donc ou nucléaire oui
alors ça c'est ce qui est différencie la
fameuse bombe sale dont vous parliez
dont on parle ici des autres la bombe
sale elle peut être si vous voulez c'est
une c'est une charge conventionnelle
avec effectivement des déchets
radioactifs ça peut même être toutes
sortes ça peut être des déchets médicaux
veut dire qu'on peut pas la tracer alors
moins de manière beaucoup plus difficile
que l'anticiper et anticiper ce que nous
voyons par exemple quand on a vu un
certain nombre de trains avec énormément
de blindés ça correspond évidemment avec
d'autres matériaux dessus à ce qui
pourrait apparaître en termes de
satellites sur un déplacement consistant
par exemple à vouloir utiliser une bombe
tactique et la différence aussi c'est
que normalement c'est bon ça dit de
salle c'est plutôt quelque chose qu'on
va retrouver dans des dans des
organisations terroristes des des
groupes subéquatiques et voilà et c'est
pas vraiment c'est c'est pas mettre
l'Ukraine sur ce plan-là c'est
sous-entendre encore une fois que le
pouvoir ukrainien n'est pas légitime que
ce sont des des gens qui ont pris le
pouvoir en Ukraine et qui occupent
l'Ukraine et qui sont donc prêts à
recourir à tout à toutes les solutions
toujours dans le registre du suspect qui
accuse l'adversaire de ses propres
turpitudes la Russie dénonce des tirs de
missiles sur le secteur de la centrale
hydroélectrique de carreur dans la
région de Kerson des des tirs que Moscou
attribue à l'armée U la mienne c'est
l'autre menace gravissime à Hamdam faire
céder ce barrage oui bien sûr on est
quand même on parle depuis très
longtemps de moments où va arriver le
tournant de la guerre bon c'est vrai
peut-être qu'il a on sait pas s'il
arrivera mais c'est vrai que ce qui se
passe en ce moment à Carson et autour de
Carson c'est quand même très inquiétant
du point de vue évidemment humain des
risques encourus et c'est aussi un peu
embêtant pour la Russie puisque personne
sait quand même symboliquement très
important pour la Russie avec Mario Paul
c'est une des villes symboliques de
l'invasion russe aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas exactement ce qui s'y passe avec
avec est-ce que à quel point les
Ukrainiens vont vont pouvoir reprendre
l'offensive mais c'est vrai que Poutine
joue beaucoup sur la psychologie dans
cette région on est sur un moment de
vérité Gauthier la Russie là est
réellement aux abois de ce qui se joue
en ce moment découlera la lecture qui
sera faite peut-être à posteriori de ce
qui a été l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine
oui mais en même temps la Russie fait
toujours elle est dans le déni permanent
le départ de cette invasion c'était un
déni aujourd'hui c'est un déni aussi
parler de la bombe sale qu'évidemment la
Russie ne voudrait pas se voir attribuer
et de dire ce sont les Ukrainiens c'est
bien une façon de vouloir la préparer
tout en disant c'est pas nous donc il y
a il s'est passé la même chose en Syrie
lorsqu'on accusait les gros problèmes de
service
vous dire et ce qui est le plus
surprenant avec cette Russie c'est
qu'elle n'affiche pas elle n'est pas
capable d'être derrière y compris sa
direction derrière ces convictions si
tentait qu'on puisse appeler ça des
convictions je m'explique s'il s'agit
vraiment de déloger des nazis à Kiev
pourquoi avoir honte de mettre les
grands moyens et ben non à chaque fois
il faut camoufler la chose on parle pas
de guerre on parle d'opération spéciale
vous voyez il y a cette volonté de la
Russie de camoufler la chose en espérant
que et là c'est pas bête en espérant
qu'entre temps l'opinion occidentale va
être victime de sa couardise potentielle
qui pointe le bout du nez avec la
fameuse lassitude ou la fatigue et qu'à
ce moment-là on dira attendez ils ont
utilisé une bombe bon c'est pas bien
mais la prochaine fois ils feront pire
et Poutine nous la fait savoir donc
négociant même s'il y a rien à négocier
en plus les Russes refusent de négocier
mais vous voyez la pression vers où elle
va contenue d'une Russie qui n'assume
pas qui n'assume pas son action qui
s'est simplement de la présenter comme
justifiable à chaque fois oui et pour
moi la date importante à suivre en
dehors de ce qui se passe maintenant
c'est le 5 décembre le jour où l'Europe
arrête vraiment d'acheter du gaz à la
Russie et le moment on va petit à petit
quand même se voir parce que pour
l'instant tout est quasiment business à
ce jeu il y a pas énormément la Russie
continue à engranger en plus même
parfois plus d'argent via la Biélorussie
une terre
à sentir l'angoisse de ce qui va se
passer donc la question c'est une fois
que ces dates sont passées et que si
Poutine installent la situation
suffisamment suffisamment bien il peut
reprendre l'avantage grâce à cela merci
Madame mustaphavi GOTY ribinsky c'est la
fin on va plus loin rendez-vous 4
minutes pour un nouveau journal d'en
parler directement
[Musique]